i reg Theodore of Maidan ed how is
everyone doing today doing great we were
looking at your numbers here since the
topic of conversation is stars sitting
out in the NBA you started 80 or more
games 10 times in your career you
averaged almost 40 minutes per game at
the age of 35 that would be the most in
the NBA this year by 2 minutes you
wanted to play but it was a different
generation when did it change where you
know you know pacing yourself and maybe
Gregg Popovich is the one who sort of
invented this but when did it happen
I think it probably started mid probably
to the early 2000s I think Popovich and
probably other coaches along with
analytics started to look at the data
and I think that's when resting players
looking at schedules as a whole and
finding out when they can rest their
stars when Tim Duncan and Manu Ginobili
and Tony Parker were resting because
people just thought it was the Spurs and
they were born and even though they were
winning championships it never really
became highlighted but it seems like
when LeBron James do it everyone's up in
arms and you know to LeBrons point you
know pop has been doing this you know
for a while now but when he does it you
know people want a call to arms I
understand where he's coming from and
his point but what LeBron needs to
understand is you have 41 home games
that that fan base is easy 41 times when
you go on the road in sit and I know
that's not the job of LeBron to fill the
arena in your building but he's got to
take into account you know the NBA fan
base because the NBA has always been
marketed by its superstars and you know
LeBron has been the face of the league
you know 10 plus years now but if
there's any player and I know I'm going
on both sides here if there's any player
that
deserves to sit out that has earned the
right to sit out it would leave it would
be LeBron you know six straight NBA
Finals but on the flip side 41 home
games if you're gonna sit out try and
sit out at home that's my point if you
want to take a game off take a game off
that cost your team and cost your
ownership and your fan base if you
really need a day off then do that
because you didn't need to take the game
off against the Clippers it wasn't a
grueling road trip where you had to take
yet a day off before you were staying in
town for the Lakers game and III
understand that LeBron feels like this
is the LeBron rule here but there's only
five guys reg that really factor in here
I'm gonna guess and that's LeBron Steph
Curry Kevin Durant Russell Westbrook and
James Harden would you say that's fair
that if you're gonna say you know a
consensus of you're gonna show up and
you want to see these stars play would
it be those five easy no question and
again LeBron James being the face of the
league a four-time MVP
it's safe to say almost do Cleveland as
well as the Brawn that's probably the
number one draw in the NBA I know you've
got you know the greatest show on the
floor in the Golden State Warriors and
Steph Curry and KD but LeBron James six
straight NBA Finals
now Daniel that's taxing on the body I
can understand where LeBron is coming
from but you just highlighted if you
have a day off before and you're staying
in LA to play the Lakers after the
Clippers it's a little head scratching
and it's almost penalizing that clipper
fan base that when the schedule came out
and they knew that the Cavs were gonna
be in Staples Center you know i
contending team like the Clippers you
know if you want to sit out so I ought
to get some makers in yeah not against
the Lakers
you could you could beat the Lakers if
you sat on you your team would probably
beat the Lakers without you
yeah but it'd be a much tougher game for
the Cavs to win versus the Clippers
without you which we saw it was it but
would you be different if you played now
Reggie just to be fair to today's stars
that if you had players who were sitting
out a couple of games here there would
you be doing that and the way I was
raised in a military household where you
got to earn your keep
you know you listed the numbers which I
did had no idea I felt guilty when I
didn't play even when I've had a
sprained ankle and I was able to play at
70 75 percent and I knew I could go I
would feel guilt sitting out because I
felt that I knew I probably could still
shoot was I would I be able to move
laterally on that ankle probably not but
I knew if the ball came to me and I was
wide open I still could be able to shoot
and that would help my team so I felt
guilty by not being on the floor I felt
guilty by leaving Dale and Antonio and
Rick Smits out there so I always wanted
to play it was I just felt if if you
were healthy enough if you could run up
and down if you could contribute to your
team you played but on the flip side Dan
I get it it isn't really we've made this
league so soft nowadays and I get it but
it just wasn't in my DNA to sit out I'm
sorry just it's hard for me to do that
he's a Reggie Miller Reggie's don't
double duty covering the NBA but also NC
double-a hoops for Turner Sports he's in
Kansas City tomorrow night Michigan and
Oregon Purdue and Kansas did you see the
story of Ray Allen who was on the 2008
championship team in Boston they were
gonna have a reunion and and Ray is not
invited back by the Boston Celtics for
the reunion I did not see that story but
that's ridiculous if that is true again
so there's bad blood when he left Boston
to go to my I'm guessing that there's
still bad blood left there with Rondo
and kg and Paul Pierce that they they're
not even inviting him back in the
offseason well that's not right because
that's not them inviting them back
that's management
so something's going wrong above Rondo
and no I think this is just the guys I
think the team is getting together and
having a reunion but they didn't invite
him but that's if that's if that is true
that's ridiculous because Ray Allen
helped win a lot of ball games and a
championship along with Rondo and Paul
Pierce and kg you know there was a
reason why originally they were the big
three and soon group grew into the big
four because of Rondo's play and for
them to hold a grudge because he decided
to join the Bron James and Dwyane Wade
in South Beach
and by the way win another championship
you know to me that almost kind of adds
to why he should be invited how great a
player he was and and first-ballot
hall-of-famer so guys need to stop being
petty
um what I'm thinking here this is what
I'm thinking because let's face it
between Boston and Cleveland and Boston
and Miami and LeBron James there's a lot
of history there especially between Paul
Pierce and LeBron James and there was a
lot of things during those series when
Ray Allen played for Boston that was
said in the locker room things like you
can never go there and play I can never
play for LeBron James
there's things that's always said that
you never think are gonna get out so
when one of your players defects or
signs with that team that you were
talking so bad about in the locker room
which Ray Allen did I think those guys
felt betrayed but at the end of the day
those guys need to understand that Ray
Allen was a huge part to their success
of winning the only championship in
their career so they kind of need to let
it go
I saw where LeBron James not pleased
with Lavar ball using hit talking about
LeBron's kids who I think are 12 and 9
and saying that they can't possibly be
great or as great as their dad because
their dad was so great that if you look
at some of the stars they're stars
because you know their dad's weren't
stars and LeBron said you know keep your
mouth shut don't mention my kids what do
you make of LeBron it is he being too
sensitive here
Lavar ball pointing out Yossi and he
points out some you know real examples
like you know Kobe's dad or Steph
Curry's dad that they've surpassed them
Shaq you know buddy then he also points
out that Shaq's kids didn't amount to
his dad that they Michael Jordan's kids
didn't amount to anywhere near his dad
and that he thinks that this is gonna
happen with LeBrons kids oh why don't
you just go to baseball and talk about
the griffeys and the bonds too
look this is three weeks in a row that
every time I've come on here it's always
been
Lavar ball conversation and I get that
you always want to speak positive about
your kids and you want to hold your kids
on the pedestal and rightfully so I
think every parent parent has the right
to do and say that and you know it's
interesting because I listen to the
comments from Lonzo and lamelle oh and
and all the kids me Angele Angele talk
about what that that's just you know dad
being dead and we take it with a grain
of salt he's always said you know things
like that so you know we really as a
family don't pay him any mind but the
rest of the basketball community and
people do and to me I just think he's
joined his kids a disservice I get that
you know you want to instill confidence
you know with your kids but when you
start bringing in Steph Curry and you
know LeBron James and you know you make
these off-the-wall comments again that
bull's eye just seems to get bigger and
bigger and you know these kids are gonna
be playing at the next level where
there's gonna be stuff waiting on them
LeBron LeBron waiting on them so yeah
it's it's unfortunate at times you just
want him just to shut the hell up
really just shut up and let these kids
play man because I'm telling you that
bullseye was gonna I would take it
personal if I was in the league I would
take it personal I really would it has
nothing to do Lonzo is a fantastic
player we'll probably the number one or
number two pick in this coming draft but
man each and every night he laces them
up and it's not even like Russell
Westbrook
harden in the elite point guards there's
going to be you the mid-range point
guards they're gonna go after Alonzo
ball because of you know what Papa said
Papa don't preach
Papa stop pretty good I'm in trouble
deep you've got Michigan Oregon Purdue
Kansas the best player with those four
teams in Kansas City is who I say the
best talent is probably the freshman
Josh Jackson for Kansas if I had to put
money in Vegas who I think the best
player is I'm gonna go with Purdue's big
man Caleb swanigan this guy he's a
medium a lot of speed down low he's a
walking double-double almost 19 points
and 13 rebounds but he has that kind of
silky smooth touch where he can take you
out two three the best player in my
opinion who is probably going to you
know garner all the intention when he
touches the basketball and when the
basketballs thrown to him is Caleb from
Purdue I'm looking at the 87 draft at
Jerry Krause passed away the Bulls GM
and there was the trade with olden
Polynice and Scottie Pippen the night of
the draft and you were 11th you were
taking 11th in that draft right Scottie
was taken I believe was his seventh in
that trade he was a bit they went up and
traded Polynice was eight and then they
traded for one another Horace Grant went
before you here's the thing what's funny
in that draft because at the time you
know in Chicago now that's where they
have the pre-draft workout and Moody
Bible yes ed Moody Bible you know in 87
we had this it was in Maui Hawaii we had
a big tournament that's where all the
draftees win and you played pickup games
and all the scouts were there the teams
and all that and you know Scotty he
really came out of nowhere you know from
a small school Central Arkansas believer
Little Rock Arkansas central and no one
had really heard of him but he played
fantastic in Maui
remember you know talking to him he's
like ah man I just hope to get drafted
and no one really knows who I am and you
know I'm just gonna come out here and
play hard and the next thing we know
here Scottie Pippen and then the you
know draft day the trade for Scottie
Pippen I'm like who is this kid now
everyone knows later obviously who's
Scottie Pippen is but give Jerry Krause
a lot of credit understanding that
Superman was going to have to need a
Batman a Robin yeah someone who was
going to be able to help
MJ out not only at the offensive end
it'd be that defensive guy and Scottie
was that guy
Scottie was it Scottie was Robin I
covered that draft so did we cross paths
I had you going higher you did yeah but
I meant higher like a number like you
know like 18 19 or could you imagine
what your career what would your career
been like if the Bulls had taken you
instead of Scottie Pippen I don't know I
I don't know nor do I care you and you
and Jordan couldn't have coexisted as
what you're saying well that was before
the bad blood between MJ and I I'm sure
I don't learn too I'm glad I I'm glad I
never got the chance
look it was fun playing against him what
now that I sit back would have been nice
to have some jewelry on my love it while
you're competing against them it was the
best I'll never take that away I love
going against them as opposed to playing
with Oh reg we'll be on the call
double-header it's Michigan in Oregon
it's Purdue and Kansas coverage starts
tomorrow night in Kansas City been fun
listening to your reg have fun coming up
tomorrow night
these are you're always the best Danette
you guys are always spot-on
that's a Reggie Aloysius Miller the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you